only the second time a commercial
Mission has launched for the
International Space Station three space
rookies and their Commander a former
NASA Pioneer once again Peggy Whitson is
shooting High heading back to space at
age 63. it was a home away from home for
me and I really want to experience it
again this time commanding a commercial
mission to the space station America's
most experienced astronaut last left the
ISS in 2017. she took three trips there
as a NASA astronaut totaling a record
665 days in space with 10 spacewalks
another record for women her Axiom 2
crew includes two Saudi government
astronauts including the first Saudi
woman in space and John schoffner a 67
year old Knoxville entrepreneur pilot
and lifelong adventurer